they grow up so fast so i just want to
cherish these but it's like
my pre-billionaire days i just want to
really own these because i know how easy
it's going to be to lose sight of these
when i when i do become a billionaire i
so for the record i don't think that
whatever i start is a guaranteed success
but to sam's point my my point was just
that
what i want to do is
focus on gaining as many skills as
possible so that when i take my shot
it's a good shot versus i see a lot of
people who are like it's time to drop
out of college because i think i'm going
to be successful
steph why are you not working for
yourself why do you have a job are you
working for these other companies why
are you making guys like sam rich
she's she's got a good answer
so my answer let's see if sean thinks
it's a good answer my answer is that
currently i get paid well to do things
that i like and i have the freedom to
work on my side projects which i do and
is like a prerequisite to work anywhere
and so i personally like the financial
stability and the mental stability
knowing i get a good paycheck to do
things i love and then that means all of
my side projects are purely for fun like
you know that like con or the comments
saying where it's like you know a
full-time job
no full-time job is fun right so if i
made my passions my full-time job full
focus then
i actually don't think i'd have as much
fun so eventually i do want to work on
my things alone but
i'm pretty happy with my setup yeah but
you're the second part you barely touch
upon so sean what she told me one time
and she said it very clearly she goes
yeah
i was like are you gonna start a
business soon she goes yeah i am i'm
just plotting because when i start it
i'm going to become a billionaire and i
just want to make sure that like i'm
ready for all that to happen uh like
like she's like very clearly told me
like whatever she starts it's gonna
become a billion dollar company and she
was like so i'm happy
yeah she was like
she was like i'm happy just to be doing
this what i love and building up like my
bank account and savings but when i do
start something um i think i'm gonna
become a billionaire
it's like oh i know but they grow up so
fast so i just want to cherish these but
it's like
my pre-billionaire days i just want to
really own these because i know how easy
it's going to be to lose sight of these
when i when i do become a billionaire
i so for the record i don't think that
whatever i start is a guaranteed success
but to sam's point my my point was just
that
what i want to do is
focus on gaining as many skills as
possible so that when i take my shot
it's a good shot versus i see a lot of
people who are like it's time to drop
out of college because i think i'm going
to be successful and i actually learned
this from one of my very first jobs i
was like a contractor doing social media
for a company and it was this woman who
was just like so poised so put together
and
successful and she was probably around
35 and i asked her that same question
i'm like why did you start your company
now like why didn't you start it 10
years ago and she told me the same thing
she's like steph a lot of people miss
the value of learning
for you know years in their career from
people who have a lot more experience
than you and who can basically like
teach you
all the obstacles that you can miss so
that when she went into building this
company which was a success off the
ground
she just knew what she was doing right
she wasn't stumbling around so i kind of
i'm trying to embody that that that
advice from that woman i thought it was
actually pretty wise i'm gonna disagree
with that advice
um
and the reason why i disagree i'm almost
hesitant to even say this because uh you
know everybody should do what they want
to do and i fundamentally believe that
so you know and if you're happy doing
what you're doing fantastic it's not
like a career advice to you so i'm kind
of talking to you but i'm really i'm
just talking to like anybody who's
listening to this
uh which is
the best way to build your skills so
that you'll be successful when you go do
that thing is to go do that thing now
and just keep doing it until you figure
it out
figuring out other games to try to then
parlay them into the game you want to
play
that works when you didn't realize what
game you want to play right so like
i learned a lot of skills in poker that
helped me in business but if i wanted to
be great at business i would do business
not poker um it's just at the time i
didn't know i wanted to do business i
thought i wanted to do poker and so
those skills yes they do cross over they
will help me for sure
um
but like all the things you're saying
sound good sound reasonable
they're just a story that you're telling
yourself like if you really wanted to go
do that thing you should go do the thing
and the fastest way to get good at that
and to like you know be good right off
the bat or like you know like
i don't know sam you've done many
businesses i'm sure each time you do one
now you have a higher likelihood of
success than you did before
but it's not like you just do them and
they just magically work now because
you've you've you've crossed the magical
threshold of skills and knowledge and
wisdom that now mean
businesses that you start will succeed
no way right it's like and it's always
changing every market's different every
business is different timing is always
different
and so like the reality is if you if
you're doing it to build up skills
you're building the wrong skills the
skills to build is to go if you're
building up skills to go start a
business the best way to build that
skill is to go start businesses um
these skills that you have today will
help you don't get me wrong it's just
not the up like you're taking the long
path rather than the the direct path um
that's kind of my my pushback
i think i have something in my contract
where i say
uh first kids comments i can't persuade
i can't persuade
is it there don't i have like a thing of
my contract where i can't like poach our
uh
our past people yeah so i i can't really
say too much except uh i think steph
should do whatever makes her happy but
and she's pretty much capable of doing
anything she wants and by the way all
right guys i quit
i'm kidding i'm done
you know the other thing is that not
everybody actually wants to be an
entrepreneur there's a whole bunch of
ways to have uh like the fun of business
building without the stress of business
building and so like for some people i
think that's the honest answer is like
actually i want to work in a small team
i don't want to go to sleep every night
worried about how to make the whole
[__] thing work i like that you go to
sleep worried about that and i worry
about my part and i enjoy my part like
and that's the trade i want to make and
i think that like more people should be
honest with that's the case for them and
they say
you know right now at this phase of my
life i don't want that stress that's
that to me means more than like
i'm building my skills up right it's
like
because once you do commit to doing a
business it is
you know there's no like kind of way
there's you know it's not really an easy
way out and um you know it's pretty
full-on commitment and i don't think you
should just make full-on commitments
unless you like want to and we're ready
to and are down to deal with like the
pros and cons of that and so like i have
a bunch of people who work for me that i
tell them i say look
there's like three scenarios here either
you suck and you're fired
um you're great and you're you're great
and you're going to realize you're great
you're going to grow here right so
you're great and you're going to grow
your impacts and grow your comp is going
to grow your your rewards are going to
grow here
or we're going to realize that like
you're you need to be doing your own
thing in which case you know i'll be
your first kind of like backer investor
or i'll partner with you on something in
some way and i just try to be honest
with people like i i kind of only want
you to land in one of those three spots
uh there's not really like another spot
there's not really like another landing
destination like this flight only goes
those three places and so you know
choose which one which one you want
i think that's smart though because a
lot of businesses treat people like
there's like 10 outcomes and they kind
of slot people like oh you're pretty
good so we'll keep you around or like
you're not that bad so we're not going
to fire you but really like if you're
trying to operate a business effectively
it should be mostly those three outcomes
like you're either amazing you're
driving value so we want you around
we're going to incentivize you to do
that or
like there's probably somewhere better
for you
[Music]
you